you know we need we need cr critical
conservative theory so
all the conservatives here you go
critical theory
was you know the marxist uh rooted very
much in the markets ideology of
oppressors and depressed
based on class i was actually just
reading some good ol
critical race theory to better
understand what they're talking about
and kimberly crenshaw wrote
that they they coined the phrase
critical race the around purpose so that
people understood it came from the
marxist framework of critical theory but
critical theory uh and marxism didn't
understand
american racism so they needed to take
his philosophy of oppressed and
oppressor and apply it to racial
politics united states
so we'll do the same thing now and we'll
create critical political theory and it
states that
if you are a liberal you're an oppressor
and if you're a conservative you're
oppressed
there you go guys that one's free feel
free to claim that you're now victims
yes there you go the problem is it won't
work
because the whole point of marxism
is to create struggle and it divides
people into different groups
makes them struggle and those groups
divide up into more groups and they
fight and fight et cetera et cetera
intersectionality i don't think it can
be solved by
people fighting each other right people
need to
develop compassion and and
because you know if you if any time
you're like arguing with people on the
internet is a nightmare and no one
should ever do it
i speak from experience pretty much uh
but when you're when you're actually
face to face with
someone it it comes down to basically
like you know somebody feels like
they're being attacked even if you
are completely wrong if you feel like
you're being attacked
you will either respond in three ways
fight flight or paralysis
and so if somebody feels like they're
being attacked that's what's going to
happen
you have to make connections with people
based on like our common humanity
because that is the anticipation of
marxism that we
have we have a shared common humanity
there are
objective truths it seems like the
the the you know the philosophy of
marxism is just to
a tactic for destroying a system to
steal to steal power
you know i made the point the other day
like a lot of people say oh communism
has never worked
that's not true communism has worked
everywhere it's been tried because the
point of communism is to create
death and destruction it's designed to
destroy a society
yeah they just pretend it's about
helping you and making the world a
better place but it's actually about how
can i empower myself
and i i experienced this with occupy
wall street the activists literally said
you know they would say we want to flip
the pyramid over now to the untrained
flipping the pyramid over implies the
working class will now be on top
and the capital will be forced to be on
the bottom what it really means is what
i asked
if you flip a pyramid over the bricks
crumble into a disheveled pile
with only one of those bricks in the
working class sitting on top and they're
and they're like and that'll be us
and where will the gua would live
in the bellies of of the people they
possess
so this is the social justice stuff is
very much a trojan horse
which is probably something that you you
noticed yon me when you were at columbia
was that this guise of compassion
and kindness how did they couch it to
you when you were first learning about
social justice at your school do they
present as something highly positive or
did they force you to do this stuff
it wasn't just so i remember at the
orientation right
and then she was like instructor came so
who likes like uh jane austen i was like
yeah me right
right yeah and because i didn't have
love i love like reading about
romance books and then like do you know
this or colonial mindset bigots racist
wow so even when you think you don't
know you're just reading a classic
you're being subconsciously brainwashed
by this white supremacist
so this is how you gotta be aware how
you can get pretty much
every day and like wow
did you speak up and say hey actually
i'm from north korea and
uh yeah i did it so before the club in
the
the class where there's like a western
civilization museum art in colombia you
have to take in a core curriculum
and then professor who has a problem
studying western civilization like the
music
and everybody like raising their hands
and they said because of this white man
killed our minority and silenced women
we have to now study this bet
you know better than mozart's biggest
wow
i'm like they were talented you know
like
this is musicians so like that
critically steering
every single thing they find a
connection somehow
it's so smart they're so so creative to
look at the problem that way
isn't it it's oppressed or oppressor
mozart
oppressor binary yeah they're now saying
beechover was black though it was not
he wasn't but they're actually now
arguing
that because of white supremacy
beethoven couldn't actually be marketed
as a black man so they had to change his
race
no joke wow there they uh there was this
big thing where they started claiming
that a black man invented the light bulb
and that thomas edison you know just
took credit for it but thomas edison was
not a cool dude
don't get me wrong but i think the
actual story was that a black man who
worked for thomas edison uh developed
a specific special filament yeah but but
historical revision revisionism is very
very important right
they need to get to the point where they
can tell us that there is this
individual who has got
and that you have to believe it or else
they need to get to the point where
people can't defend themselves we'll
stop resisting and we'll just give up so
every day that people challenge the
system and say no
is a bad day for this this machine but i
i also will say
at least for now i don't think there is
a grand architect
or conspiracy or group that are trying
to make it happen i think
you could argue there's a conspiracy in
the sense that a bunch of people who
have a worldview rooted in this don't
realize they're destroying everything
around them
some people for sure know they're lying
cheating and stealing
but it feels like domino's falling over
you know joe biden doesn't seem to be
all with it
but he hears what people saying critical
race theory is good he goes okay
mark milly the general he has no idea
what he's talking about
he goes i just want to understand white
rage and it's like bro that's insane
you're in
you're believing garbage more and more
people believe it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
i think this is where the beautiful
language stuff
comes in because if you you know people
call people useful idiots
kind of but it's kind of more like most
of them are well-meaning innocence
i've heard that term where like really
they're just
you know they they want to be better
people like you were saying chris
and they want to but like the beautiful
language really
just it kind of pulls the wool over the
eyes of a lot of people
and it's on purpose you see this in
every communist society
where i mean in china they just came out
with a white paper
the communist party about uh you know
how how the communist party in china has
led human rights for a hundred years
they've been the leader
of human rights uh you know because
we've you know like this is the time
where like they killed 80 million people
yeah but they're like yeah no we've
definitely you know they redefine human
rights
they say you know we talk about the
universal
universality of human rights within the
context of each country
so they're already saying human rights
are universal but we're gonna change
what
this means for human rights and then
they go we believe that human rights are
subsistence development
and contentment and therefore these are
like the metrics that we're using to say
that we've
you know we've lifted so many million
people out of poverty
you know we are the leader in huma in
human rights
but it's even absurd even if you use
that standard because they
killed and starved and like 80 million
people
so but like they're able to kind of take
this term that sounds great human rights
that everybody's like these are
universal
you know the un says human rights are
universal and then they kind of
can come and like twist that to mean
something else
and then make themselves look good that
is so interesting to me that they call
it the beautiful language
because this is exactly what they're
doing in the us they're
changing these terms and this is why i
brought up the topic of definitions
yesterday
when you're going into a debate you lay
out your definitions before you even get
started nothing proceeds until you know
exactly where everyone stands
and where everything is lined up and
this is why they won't define
this is why post-modernism is so
dangerous it's because they defy
definition it's it's one of their
stronger points it's basically what
makes post-modernism what it is
it gives them this ability to kind of
change the way
you perceive the world and when you're
arguing with them oh well i didn't mean
that that doesn't mean that anymore
that used to mean that it's evolved
critical race theory
yes christopher ruffo goes on joy reads
show on msnbc
and says critical race theory is rooted
in marxism and she goes no it isn't
and he's like uh intersectionality is
rooted in critical race there no it's
not
this author is a critical racers no she
isn't and
everything he said was true and
verifiable
but they changed the definitions she
goes
robin d'angelo isn't a critical race
theorist she's a critical white
studies author of course critical right
studies is a component of critical race
theory
they just try and make it as confusing
as possible so you can never criticize
them
they cement it's all semantics i mean it
is like orwell
wrote in 1984 it's like you lose a
language to describe objective reality
and it drives you crazy right and that's
i mean like that's really destructive i
think this is when i'm
shocked something i think these are
defectors in the beginning having a hard
time because in north korea
words like it doesn't mean anything i
mean like
right like that music no words like
words mean nothing is in tv like say
oh maybe leaving the social is paradise
blah blah i mean
there's never a bad news right so
everything that you study in school
is not really relevant to your actual
life when i came here
i was so shocked how seriously the words
meant to people and
i don't know it's so insane i don't know
how they did that in north korea
i mean it's it's kind of the way that a
communist is it
like the regime like destroys society in
a certain sense because you destroy the
meaning of language so like everybody's
a liar
yeah you have to be a liar all the time
for your survival
and then there's nothing right well uh
you made a stargate reference earlier
yes i did
sg-1 though well i guess so in the movie
they go to this this other planet
through the star games
portal and when they try and write on
the ground
the the the slaves there freak out like
writing is forbidden what are you doing
and they're like we're trying to convey
an idea to you through it's like you
can't do that and it's because when
people have the ability to communicate
you know they become dangerous they
share ideas they become they become more
knowledgeable
they start to understand the collective
computational power of a large group of
people is a lot
so to keep people oppressed you must
limit their ability to understand
reality and share those ideas
well this is why i think the united
states of america has always been the
greatest enemy to communism you know it
states
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created
equal that there is this uh
i mean they called it like nature or the
creator
that gives people inalienable rights
this is different from
most other countries that you you don't
have
freedom of speech or freedom of religion
because the government grants you that
you have it because you're human you
have this because some
something beyond human understanding has
made it an
innate part of your existence and that
creates an objective reality
that is the opposite of communism like
shelley was talking about with
human rights in china what they're
saying is we have our definition of
human rights you have your definitions
of human rights
don't enforce your values don't push
your values on
us and but and then you get lost in like
all these word games but if you just
zoom out
and like what the chinese communist
party is doing to the uyghurs
is evil right what it's doing to falun
gong is evil what it's doing to all the
chinese people
is evil that is objective truth
the one thing that greatly benefits
china in the international conflict
where we're trying to convince people
who's right who's wrong is
the narrative of black lives matter in
the united states about some grand
institutionalized racism where they come
out and say look what you're doing to
these minorities
and it's all exaggerated or extreme or
at the very least they hyper focus on
some stories that make it seem like the
whole
of the country is racist or broken i
mean that's what chinese propaganda has
been doing about the us for years
um every day there's a 30-minute chinese
news show
that plays on every channel
right and like it's always whenever they
talk about america it's always about how
dangerous
and violent and racist and whatever how
bad it is
and so this stuff about critical race
theory is kind of just like
it's exactly the same thing and they are
so happy the chinese communist party
like loves this they use it
all the time like they can just say oh
well you can't criticize us for
wuhan uh the live league or the
coronavirus i mean they won't admit it's
a lab league but you know you say that
it's racist um there was a incident that
happened in the u.n last week where
canada was about to bring up that there
should be an investigation
into the uyghur genocide and the
chinese representative stood up and was
like preemptively said
actually there needs to be an
investigation to canada for what
happened to the indigenous children
you know like like he just like right
before the canadian
official was going to say something just
came up in a classic
communist party move yeah yeah so yeah
they love this you know you know you
know what's funny
there's a it's like a joke idea um
what if we are actually in north korea
not like literally the physical space
like what if people in america
are the ones who think they're so smart
and think they know the world but
it's all propaganda it's all
manipulation it's all controlled
and then actually in these other
countries they have spaceships and they
have
you know 100 years more advanced
technology the idea is that for a lot of
people you just believe what the tv
tells you is believe the newspapers tell
you
i suppose the difference is the united
states we have these kinds of
conversations that challenge our own
understanding of the world we also have
freedom of movement so we can go to
these other countries or meet people in
these countries
you can't though you can go to a lot of
countries but there are some countries
you can't go to
american passport will not get you in
not in north korea
i have to take your word for it and you
might be cia
yeah see that proves it i know
yeah but there are a lot of countries
you can't get into
no i i i think it's a funny idea but uh
you
the fact that you can even mention this
idea that our government does lie to us
of course they lie to us there's
classified information they have to lie
in some circumstances
but they lie when they shouldn't and
there's a lot of people who are corrupt
but then
our media lies to us all the time as
well i do think it's funny when we talk
about the things china is doing
and you know you mentioned that china's
got this program where they say all
these things about the united states
we got the same thing sort of right
we've got these corporate
american deep state whatever media that
just say whatever the establishment
wants them to say
granted we also have the internet with
some free speech still available to the
rest of us but more so than these
many of these other countries i mean the
great thing for china is that the
american
corporate media is saying the same thing
as the chinese propagandists
especially during the entire corona
virus yeah
the the solid they did for china oh yeah
and youtube's saying you can't uh speak
out against the world health
organization what they say
is law don't say anything that
contradicts them
well even worse this is something we
covered recently like a lot of these
medical journals early on that we're
saying
uh you know it's lab leak hypothesis
complete conspiracy theory
uh not only were they quoting scientists
like dr peter dadzik who was working
with the wuhan institute of virology
right
china is giving money to some of the
biggest medical journals in the world
lancet and springer nature right yeah
springer nature and
elsevier who is the parent company of
lancet they get a lot of money from
china to publish open access journals
so somebody estimated that springer
nature's deal with china is worth like
10 million a year
you want you want to i i think it's much
worse than anybody realizes
let me explain to you guys how easy it
is to control the american narrative
especially with something like youtube
youtube is one of the greatest vehicles
for political propaganda ever created
let's say you're china you want the
american public to believe
your lies in your propaganda it's simple
take a large portion of your money and
then
buy ads on the youtube channels
that say the things that you like it's
that simple
what ends up happening is youtube sees
that oh advertisers really love
these particular youtubers they generate
a ton of ad revenue prop them up boost
them in the algorithm
they get prominent positioning they get
more and more views
they become wealthy and successful they
hire people and expand their companies
it's that simple there's no way to track
it unless google
was audited and forced to reveal where
the money is coming through but it's
very
it works in any capacity any individual
can run any videos an ad and anybody can
buy an advertisement and choose to run
it on a specific channel
so if you find somebody who's producing
a show called like
china you know the youtube channel
called why china is right
and every day they do an hour video
where as an american they're like this
lies in propaganda china is great
some political actor might not be able
to physically fund that
without an ad appearing youtube will say
this is a chinese sponsored
but the chinese government could put
money into a company which then
advertises
sneakers and they say we want to run all
of these ads for sneakers
on this channel unless china is right on
this china is right channel and you
think this china is right channel would
make a lot of money
it makes a lot of money because they're
giving the money to the creator and to
google google doesn't take
notes well so think about it right
if you guys have a youtube channel the
us government could be secretly putting
money into google and you would never
know as an individual
you would not know because google just
says hey here's how much money you made
in ads and you have no idea where the
ads came from or what the ads are for
i thought people they mentioned to me
like oh i got a bloomberg ad on your
video once
this is back during the election or
whatever primaries and i'm like good i
rag on the guy all the time so if he's
paying me to rag on him
it's understandable that he wants to try
and counter that narrative but i don't
think you guys buy it right
i think my audience is smart enough to
realize the dude's full of it he's
buying political ads
and i'll take his money but what if what
if it's more
insidious than that what if it's a
company for air conditioners
just every ad spot that you have so this
there's ad
inventory your video could be a certain
amount of minutes maybe it's 15 minutes
and a youtube ad can appear every
certain amount of minutes and the
algorithmically
they they restrict how many ads can
appear not every video sells
every possible ad space but what if you
were
uh china you saw a youtuber who was
constantly saying things good about you
you could indirectly make sure every
single
available ad on that channel was paid
for and that youtuber is now making tons
of money
successful and driven to produce more of
the content they're doing because it
works
china's doing it simpler they're just
they're just directly paying
some youtubers and i don't think those
youtubers have like a
state sponsored no right they're a bunch
of like like white pro china youtubers
suddenly
who are going to xinjiang and walking
around saying there's no genocide here
wow look at this cotton field where's
the genocide there was uh
this really creepy moment where chyna
was uh
asking people to upload a video to their
youtube channels
where it was a guy complaining about a
falun gong show in new york city they
were like
i think it was falun gong i'm not sure
it was some like
theater show and he was like
this is wrong and creepy why is this
religious
organization being allowed to put on
this show and you you'd get an email and
they were like we'll give you 200
to upload this to your channel right now
and oh yeah i heard about this
yeah yeah that's super weird
yeah i think it's against the rules but
maybe not maybe not
do you guys feel like this is capitalism
defeating itself
like the fact that people are being able
to monetize this
money that's available to weaponize
information against the way that the
west has become
powerful that's kind of what i've been
thinking
this might be kind of a tangential
answer to that question but i think
like i don't believe in capitalism i
think that's a that's a marxist kind of
construct
you have communism or you have
capitalism
and that's not really true it's like you
have freedom to engage in the economy
it's it's not it's freedom yeah
capitalism
existed as like the normal normal human
mode of
trade and economics and then marx kind
of gave a name to it
right right right right yeah it was just
enterprise
yeah and while also ignoring that you
know there were other systems like
mercantilism
or subsistence farming it just blames
all the problems in history that guy was
nuts
dude i hear he smelled bad too racist
gross
he should be canceled for his racism he
actually was kind of racist right
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time